ddr4 memory has been off for a couple of
years now and it is very mainstream with
most PCs and laptops shipping with it
and most PC billers optic port rumors
for DDR pyria have been ongoing for
several months and many of these rumors
are suggesting that 2019 will be the
year for ddr4 Ram 2019 is pretty much
here so should you hold out on buying or
building a PC and wait for ddr4 Ram
instead one of my opinion no and here's
why welcome to Haris hobbies first of
all even if ddr5 really does come out in
2019 most rumors are suggested that it
will not come out till the end of 2019
ddr4 Ram was released in September 2014
so we may see another September release
but something you do have to keep in
mind that is that it will take a couple
of months for all the manufacturers to
implement this new ran into their RAM
sticks so unless you want to buy the
first Ram stick that comes to ddr5 then
you're going to have to wait a couple of
months until manufacture that you want
it comes out with it IG Seco or Corsair
so the first issue is that you probably
won't even be able to get your hands on
the ramp that you want until the end of
train ID
however you can't just use it right then
either there's another issue that you
have to face I can't confirm this but
chances are very high that ddr4 Ram will
not work with current generation
motherboards especially concerned that
there will be a huge speed boost like
the leaks are suggesting Intel usually
launchers their new CPUs in October so
Intel follows the same path then
technically one of our manufactures
could offer ddr5 motherboards to go
along with Intel's new CPUs however at
that point d-dear of time is still so
new
and unless ddr5 is backwards compatible
with the year before which I highly
doubt because this is not happened in
the past motherboard manufacturers are
probably just going to stick with ddr4
Ram AMD usually don't just a mainstream
CPUs in March or April and I think this
is really when you're going to be seeing
those new ddr5 motherboards so you're
going to have to wait till spring of
2020 not even use your new ddr5 Ram on
other huge point to consider is that
once ddr5 Ram comes
manufacturers are going to want to get
rid of their ddr4 Ram as soon as
possible so next holiday season they'll
probably offer a really good discounts
on it
well did he reply Ram will not budge
from MSRP as a result if you're looking
at building a new PC next holiday season
then chances are the best thing you can
do is get a new sent to CPU with ddr4
Ram and honestly that really is the best
option because unless you're doing some
really highly intensive Ram tasks DDR my
Ram isn't going to make that big of a
difference in ddr4 we will save a lot of
money in the scenario as a result while
gr5 memory may be coming out later in
2090 it won't really be till 2020 that
will be mainstream and worth it you will
have to wait till spring of 2020 to
actually buy a nice ddr5 system and have
a good amount of options if you want a
good deal it won't be till the holiday
season of 2020 so that's really quite a
Wells out thus if you're looking at
building a PC soon that forget about
ddr5 ramp right till ami reveals your
news then two CPUs to see all the
options you have and it's build a nice
ddr4 system but that's just what I think
what do you guys think what do you think
DDR my RAM is going to be coming out and
how fast do you think it'll be
make sure comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like some give me make
sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm hard I'll see you guys on the next
one